4 Essential Readings for High School
where you will find all the literary motifs
doll early spring
Crime and Punishment and Grandfathers Part 3.
I will mention only a few motifs from each of them
in the doll you will find love
friendship work utopia
city image of society
in crime and punishment guilt Punishment
crime loneliness
love woman
early spring rebellion
The Mother Revolution
in the grandfathers part 3 the role of the poet and the poetry of bards
individualism
fight patriotism
Image of Society
If you can read these 4 books
for sure you will write an essay on Polish bites
From tomorrow there will be an outline every day
matriculation with the use of
These 4 readings
I invite you to follow